yeah Mike and Adam have obviously been
working too hard but why is Josh panting
like a steam train when mammals get too
hot their main way of cooling off is
through a process called evaporative
cooling and this is essentially the
process that turns water from a liquid
to a vapor absorbing energy with it as
it doesn't in humans
evaporative cooling takes place on our
skin where sweat glands produce sweat
which then evaporates to cool us down
because humans can sweat this
evaporative cooling takes place all over
our bodies but with dogs
it only takes place in a couple tiny
spots on their paws where they have
sweat glands so they have to find other
moist surfaces to evaporate water from
which would be their mouth their tongue
and their nasal passages those locations
have a lot of blood vessels so what he's
cooling down is the blood inside those
vessels which circulates throughout his
whole body thus cooling him off when it
comes to chilling out - has it licked no
sweat
[Music]